you were saying in the last time you
were saying we-we-we lon I didn't get to
clarify you are you are dating a younger
man by some measure by some measure now
your man you like age yeah do you notice
that their ever generational gaps
between you and sometimes well first I
noticed that any time they they mention
our ages online he seems to get younger
online like he's in real life I'll go on
record now he'll be thrilled that I let
people know he's actually 26 right but
online he's like 24 23 I'm like and then
I'm gonna be like 50 or something
60 year-old Baron there are some
generational gaps but you know mostly
we're in sync but every now and again
will come up against today we're on
vacation recently and you know there's
certain things we considered pretty much
Universal gay viewing and beaches the
film is one of them and so you can't
really be gay and not watch beaches so
yeah we were uh native Asian and we
decided to play at the same time on our
little televisions the movie so that he
could watch it for the first time and I
of course have seen it and was thrilled
to be a lane or something we were in a
play Your Honor I see you're on a plane
and you get you got a display and hard
little seats so we could watch it
simultaneously and every and he was
literally wracked with sobs like he was
just like heaving I mean sometimes the
altitude will do that to you but the
stewardess came up it was like can I get
you anything like
but you could make him so miserable what
about when it comes to music I find that
to be like sometimes there's a song that
comes on the radio and I crank it yeah
you know my kids are just like what do
you do that's really I mean I I would
say that my musical tastes are probably
much more current than they would be I
know I know a lot of the artists of the
moment that I might not know otherwise
I'm not a huge like pop because I'm very
content with like give me some Cat
Stevens give me some you know Simon and
Garfunkel right Mitchell old-school like
right where it all began like that's how
I learned you know so now I'm like Fetty
WAP and like what's that you know it's
good good stuff I can't get away with
saying that well just laugh and throw
stones at me now you've done a lot of
theater I know I you're going to do some
more theater is that right you're going
back to the stage I am going if
someone's cricket phone it's someone's
quick advice you have your bad girl you
better someone's getting their fury ever
have well it's funny that you should
mention the theater is this gladly
rickets during my monologue
that's what I hear in my head when a
joke doesn't work is one of those nights
but it's DVDs on the floor but this
really funny thing about about the
theater though when you're doing a play
like you know you never know what's
gonna happen in the audience and you
really have to roll with things like
that all the time I was I was seeing a
play years ago this amazing play called
God of Carnage in New York and the woman
next to me in the middle of like maybe
15 minutes into the show just reaches
under her seat and pulls out of
Starbucks you know coffee and then it
goes back under the seat and pulls out a
Starbucks pastry bag made of paper and
wrestles through the paper and gets out
like a croissant and like gives her
husband half of the doughnut and then
goes under the seat and gets on a box of
Red Vines and gives her husband a box of
Red Vines at which point I felt obliged
to lean over and be like this is not the
movies like you're not they can hear you
you know if so it's a very fascinating a
thing that you have to kind of cultivate
the balance to be able to roll with it
when should like that happen you do
think that like there are people that
would almost set up a hot plate and
start making if there were outlets in
the chairs just watching this incredibly
powerful scene in the theater and Death
of a Salesman while they're flipping
there yeah but I am going to do I did a
play a couple of seasons ago on Broadway
The Glass Menagerie and I'm going back
to the theater in the beginning of 2016
at the MCC theater at the Lucille Lortel
off Broadway to do a new play called
smoke fall which I'm really excited
about it's a beautiful new play by a
playwright called Noah haidle so I'm
really looking forward to that it's
great to be able to go now I live in New
York so it's great to be able to be home
and working and doing something that I
feel really excited about so yeah you
know I know you're a busy guy thank you
so much for taking the time to be with
us I really do like this fellow Zachary
Quinto we'll be right back hey thanks
for watching be sure to click subscribe
to see even more great Conan clips you
may now return to your pirated movies
and creepy Japanese pornography